the acm awards in nashville it's the
first live awards show since the
pandemic began
and we've got a sneak peek at what to
expect starting with hosts with the most
keith irvin
[Music]
you picked a hell of a year to host well
it was all going
so well kevin we were supposed to be in
vegas in april
and uh instead we will be in nashville
in september
but it's going to be a really really
good show you ready for this what can
you expect at tonight's atms
keith and pink are performing their new
song one too many
and new mom maren morris is performing
her hit to helen back
i had a baby at the beginning of the
pandemic and it's been very
disappointing to not be able to share
him in person with
my loved ones and i think that music has
been
an incredible source of inspiration
[Music]
of course taylor swift's returning to
the show after seven years
i spoke with executive producer and dick
clark's son rack who gave us details on
what's happening behind the scenes
give me the scoop about the bus farm
it's like a drive-in concert
tailgate all happening at backstage at
the acm
it's the safest way to go everybody has
their own individual pod now
we're not encouraging quote hanging out
but as long as everybody you know stay
safe we're all we're all good with that